how do the things we use every day like
apps phones and even medical devices go
from idea to finished products with the
guidance of a product manager one of
linkedin's top five most promising jobs
these are roles that are in high demand
and pay well
product managers function as a ceo of a
product effectively leading their own
startup within a company while working
cross-functionally with a variety of
teams in udacity's product manager
nanodegree program you'll define product
strategy design and test a prototype
write requirements and acceptance
criteria for product development and
create a comprehensive go to market plan
all with instructors from google and
uber
but
you won't just learn how to be a product
manager you will get hands-on experience
making real-life product decisions with
a project from crafting your own product
pitch to detailing the functionality of
your product using api documentation
to communicating with development and
marketing teams and even more giving you
the skills to be an in-demand product
manager own the decision about what gets
built but also influence every aspect of
how it gets built and launched by
becoming a product manager enroll in
udacity's product manager nano degree
program today
[Music]
you